i want to explain the best way to get
rid of acne scars
vitamin e oil if you have
scarring from acne like i did i had
really bad acne
in high school and i wish i would have
known what i know now back then because
acne is so easy to get rid of if you
know how
for those of you that are watching that
have acne i put a link down below for
that but this video is primarily on the
scarring that can occur
after you get acne if you're going to
use vitamin e oil on your face
i would highly recommend going with some
organic brand
hexane free go high quality now i don't
have any brand that i recommend you're
going to have to do that research
but vitamin e has a really significant
effect
on fibrosis breaking down scar
tissue now the studies that i looked at
relate more for
cirrhosis of the liver but i have
personally observed
quite a few people experience positive
results using vitamin e
on their scars including acne scars
because vitamin e is a very powerful
antioxidant it's fat soluble so it goes
into the skin
it's an anti-inflammatory it can break
down scar tissue
it can even help certain wrinkles on
your skin
so this is what i recommend doing i
would take some vitamin e rub it into
the skin
for about one or two minutes right
before you go to bed i would do that
every single night
for about two to three weeks and you
should see
some breakdown of that scar tissue now
if you combine this
with healthy keto and
intermittent fasting and periodic
prolonged fasting i think you're going
to even get better results because
if you're consuming a lot of carbs in
your diet that is going to block the
effect of vitamin e
and it's going to make your skin age a
lot faster
when you do fasting especially prolonged
fasting
your body goes through this thing called
autophagy where you're
recycling old damaged protein so the
body will start to clear out the old
dead cells
and replace it with the new so it's a
really good anti-aging action
now when you do prolong fasting i would
suggest
you do this every two weeks or each
month
where you're fasting for at least 72
hours even
longer to see the maximum benefit
for more information on that i put a
link down below
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not
going as smooth i have a keto consultant
standing by
to help you this is just for the people
in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call but i put the
number down below
so you can call and get some help